bonjour philippe petit bonjour bus thank
you put vous êtes candidat aux élections
législatives vous vous présentez dans le
sud sur la liste de l'union des
démocrates indépendants
première question pourquoi vous
présentez vous aux élections
législatives alors tous bonjour vous
auditez en tout parti politique doit
s'inscrire aux législatives parce que
c'est une élection qui permet d'être
connu reconnu et qui en plus fait les
fondements économiques de tous les
partis politiques ce qui est nécessaire
à la construction de la démocratie
la deuxième chose c'est qu'ils avaient
trois dames qui était désireuse parce
qu'on leur avait demandé on cherchait
des candidats de s'exprimer il fallait
les accompagner puisque je suis le plus
vieux routier le plus expérimenté parmi
ces dames il fallait les accompagner et
troisièmement mon mouvement politique
qui s'appelle du thème qui me kyi qui
vous fait mon étiquette officiel soutenu
par liddy avait besoin lui aussi de se
placer par rapport à d'autres mouvements
politiques qui existent à la martinique
que dit autonomistes ou indépendantistes
ou bien montrer qu'il n'y a pas que ça
dans le paysage politique alors quels
sont les deux ou trois projets
prioritaires pour la martinique que vous
souhaitez défendre si vous êtes élu à
l'assemblée nationale alors vous avez vu
que dans le mot idem il ya le mot
écologie c'est pas un mot à la mode
c'est connu un dérèglement climatique et
qu'il faut bien voir ce qu'on doit faire
pour la martinique les sargasses ne sont
pas une fatalité nous l'avons déjà dit
il faut aller les collecter en mer il
faut pouvoir les ramassées sur les
plages avec des appareils comme les
collecteurs mais avec des appareils
ensuite monter une usine pour pouvoir
les transformer en produits qui
servirait à faire de l'aquaculture
notamment pour ce qu'on appelle les
concombres de mer où la tuerie bref ou
de l'alevinage ce qui veut dire que
c'est un circuit
circulaire qui permettrait de donner de
la valeur ajoutée à la sargasse donc sam
sera ma première loi si je devais y
aller la deuxième ça serait probablement
qu'on ne peut pas vivre dans un pays où
on nous dit ce qui certainement
démontrer que les cancers de la prostate
cancer du sein ou autres et à des
véritables problèmes de santé dus à
l'enfouissement des pesticides sur on le
sait les tubercules et c'est donc il ya
de la recherche sur la dépollution
notamment c'est encore une économie
circulaire avec les boues d'épuration
li station d'épuration qu'on appelle
richard ensuite il faut être clair nous
avons une grande souffrance sur le tiche
économique knoxy la banque publique
d'investissement national qui a été
montée n'est pas efficace il faut la
rendre efficace puisque liée d'homme ou
en faire ce qu'il à la fdc surtout à aux
collectivités locales et c'est pas elle
seulement qu'il faut des emplois donc il
faut pouvoir trouver des relais avec les
fonds européens puisque le temps que les
fonds européens arrivent comme vous
l'avez fait un apport personnel vous ne
l'avez pas ensuite même si vous avez la
peau personnel le fonds n'arrivent pas
un iphone crédit relais dont il est
indispensable si on veut se servir de
l'europe que nous ayons cette chose là
et puis je veux évidemment pour parler
aussi des maisons de santé c'est à dire
que dans un paysage où nous avons une
démographie qui est malheureusement vers
le troisième âge pour le quatrième âge
il faut pouvoir mettre dans l'île dans
chaque commune ou dans deux ou trois
communes une maison de santé où il ya la
fois un infirmier à la fois un médecin à
la fois des aides soignantes qui peuvent
se balader dans la commune et qui
peuvent porter lors leur pierre à
l'édifice avec le système libéral des
infirmières libérales alors brièvement
qu'elle ce concernant la circonscription
le sud dans laquelle vous vous présentez
quelles seraient vos deux ou trois
priorités en tant que député alors
j'oublie un jeu je vais j'y tiens aussi
dans le marché que nous avons menti ni
guadeloupe il faut absolument la
continuité territoriale ou savez quand
on est encore son un tarif pour les
résidents on peut pas se barrer en
guadeloupe ou inversement la guadeloupe
et à la martinique pour payer un billet
d'avion de 250 euros c'est inadmissible
quand on est à 300 km de vol et aussi
pour le bateau on peut diminuer l'état
du bateau avec une loi pour que les
résidents et une prime versée par l'état
concernant le sud il est évident qu'il
ya beaucoup de marins pêcheurs il est
évident qu'il ya beaucoup d'agriculteurs
donc on pourrait dire que on serait à
leur écoute pour pouvoir écouter parce
que ce sont quand même des producteurs
qui nous ont sortis d'affaires lorsque
nous avions ici là qu'on vide
c'est-à-dire ces fameux circuit coup
donc je pense qu'il faudrait les écouter
en priorité pour pouvoir dessiner autour
de ce que j'ai dit la banque
d'investissement
par exemple les normes des marins
pêcheurs il ya des bateaux qu'on peut
mettre qui peuvent partir pour trois
jours mais dont les fonds européennes ne
sont pas structurés pour les mettre en
adéquation avec les marins pêcheurs ce
qui fait qu'ils ne partent pas trois
jours et donc il ya une déperdition
d'énergie c'est une rolls un petit peu
culturelle de nos marins pêcheurs de
partir seulement une journée mais on
peut arriver à faire des choses qui
allie l'efficacité et je dirais la
culture martiniquaise paris pour les
agriculteurs au revoir certaines choses
pour pouvoir faire de la transformation
sur certaines petites productions comme
le café le cacao peut être pas forcément
dans le sud mais on est député de
l'agriculture et puis donc voilà des
choses pratiques et puis bien entendu si
on arrive bien entendu toujours à l'idée
de la formation et je serais pour qu'ils
aient une formation beaucoup plus
poussés à la formation professionnelle
le plan nous avons les habilitations qui
soit plus pratique alors rapidement en
10 secondes qu'avez-vous d'autre à dire
aux électeurs est mis en échec les
lecteurs vous avez affaire à un pea et
un fils qui s'appelle le papa c'est
alfred marie-jeanne le fils et
jean-philippe nylon je les aime tous les
deux mais il faut que vous puissiez
changé et que vous puissiez trouver
quelqu'un de sérieux ou lieu de rentrer
dans un combat de coqs kozo et dans le
sud pas de combat de coqs un combat de
texte pour avoir de l'efficacité pour
voter des lois en la faveur de la
martinique à la faveur des habitants et
des professionnels du sud et les petits
merci
[Musique]